what does it mean to be a good man
the various role that a human being
takes on
uh in this role theory that you've
spoken about what does it mean to be a
good
it means to perform now I will do
Aristotle it means to be perform the
function well right what Aristotle says
is the good is not like moral good moral
evil in the way that we tend to think
about it he he meant that a good cup
holds liquid and a good spoon hold soup
it means that like a thing that is
broken can't hold those things right so
yeah the idea of being a good person
means that you are fulfilling the
function for which you were made it's a
teleological view of of humanity so if
you're a good father this means that you
are bringing up your child in durable
values that is going to bring them up
healthy capable of protecting themselves
and passing on the traditional wisdom of
the ages to Future Generations while
allowing for the capacity for Innovation
that'd be being a good father right
being a good spouse would mean
protecting and unifying with your spouse
and building a safe family and a place
to raise children being a good citizen
of your community means protecting the
fellow citizens of your community while
incentivizing them to build for
themselves
and they it becomes actually much easier
to to think of how to this is why I like
the role Theory because it's very hard
since sort of in virtue Theory to say be
generous okay how does that manifest I
don't know I don't know what that looks
like sometimes being generous might
being being not
generous to other people right when when
Aristotle says that you should be
benevolent like what does that mean this
is very vague when I say be a good dad
most people sort of have a gut level
understanding of what it means to be a
good dad mostly well they have a gut
level understand what it means to really
be a really bad dad uh and so what it
means to be a good man is to fulfill
those roles as many of them as you can
properly and at full function and that's
a very hard job I've said before that
you know because I engage a lot with
public and all this you know the word
great comes up a lot what does it take
to be a great leader what does it to be
a great person and I've always said to
people it's actually fairly easy to be
great it's very difficult to be good
there are a lot of it there are a lot of
very great people who are not very good
and they're not a lot of good people and
one of them most of them you know
frankly most good people
die mourned by their family and friends
and two generations later they're
forgotten but those are the people who
incrementally move the ball forward in
the world sometimes much more than the
people who are considered great
understand the role in your life that
involves being a cup and be damn good at
it exactly that's right hold the soup
it's very uh Jordan Peterson have been
there yeah it's very like lobster with
Jordan exactly I think people will quote
you for years and years to come on that